- [Narrator] This UCSD-TV
program is presented by
University of California Television.
Liked what you learned?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(mellow piano music)
- I have been a professor of medicine
and a clinical cardiologist
at UCLA for about 25 years.
But about 12 years ago
I got a telephone call
that changed my life.
And that call came from
one of the veterinarian's
at the Los Angeles zoo.
And he called me because
one of their chimpanzees
had woken up with a facial droop.
They were concerned that
she might have had a stroke.
And he asked if I'd come to
the zoo and image her heart
to look for blood cloths and other things
that might have been the problem.
And this is the hospital
at the zoo that I went to.
And this is actually me with
me my first non-human animal,
and I'm going to come back
to her in just a moment.
But a few weeks after I
visited with this chimpanzee
I was asked to rule out a
torn aorta in a gorilla.
And not long after that
there was a California condor
that they noted a heart murmur in
and they asked if I would look to see
whether one of the valves was torn,
which in fact it was.
There was a California sea lion
whose lower body had filled with fluid
and they were concerned about
congestive heart failure
and asked if I'd come.
And in this picture I'm
listening to the heart of a lion
who had had a collection
of over 700 cc's of fluid
in the sac in which
her heart is contained.
And in a collaborative procedure involving
veterinarian's and human cardiologist
we drained the fluid from her heart.
And this by the way is a procedure
that I have done on
hundreds of human patients.
But I must say that the
procedure itself was
identical to the procedure
that I've done on humans
with the exception of this.
(audience laughing)
And where is it?
There we go, and that.
Let's get back to the my first patient,
this chimpanzee who had
the suspected stroke.
I remember when I first put
the probe into her mouth
and slid it down the esophagus.
I turned to the screen
and this is what I saw.
A four chambered beating heart,
a left ventricle, a right
ventricle, two atria,
but I noticed that there were blood clots
moving these round bouncing balls,
and that the upper chambers were enlarged.
And as soon as I saw that picture
it reminded me of a human
patient I've imaged at UCLA
some weeks before
who had the enlarged
atria and the blood clots.
And I realized that these two patients,
one human and one chimpanzee
had spontaneously
developed the same kind of
infiltrative heart failure
that I have been treating for years
with high technology and
advanced pharmaceuticals.
And I found myself being
a little bit surprised.
But then I was more curios
about why I was surprised.
I mean, I certainly knew that we share
the common ancestor with chimpanzees
between five and seven million years ago,
which of course is a blink
in the scope of evolutionary time.
And as an undergraduate,
I've worked for four years in a
Museum of Comparative Zoology.
But when I gone to medical school
and like most medical students today,
what I have learned the connection between
animal and human health was,
was infectious, pathogenic, zoonotic.
And of course there is no question
that animals play an important role
in the transmission of diseases
that have a high impact
on human communities.
Even more so now the one health community
is helping us realize
that the majority of
infections that will impact
human populations are coming
from animal reservoirs.
But what I didn't learn and
most medical students don't,
is that the father of modern medicine
Sir William Osler is also considered
the father of modern veterinary medicine.
And that one of his teachers,
the father of modern pathology
Rudolf Virchow wrote in the 19th century,
"Between animal and human medicine
"there is no dividing
line nor should there be.
"The object is different
but the experience obtained
"constitutes the basis of all medicine."
But what I was finding
was that while I was taking care
of my human patients at UCLA
I would go to the zoo and I would hear
the veterinarian discuss
the management of metastatic breast cancer
or the management of brittle diabetes,
or the dosage of serotonin
reuptake inhibitor drugs
like Prozac for some of their patients
who are anxious or compulsive.
And I realized that as much
as I knew about human medicine
I knew so little about
veterinary medicine.
And it turns out there has been a gulf
between these two fields.
Now there are many reasons for that,
some are historical, some are cultural,
but I'm going to focus
on two for a moment.
The first I believe has to do
with our essential ambivalence
about embracing our own animal natures.
But the other is human exceptionalism.
We all are scientist.
Many of us are scientist here,
and we theoretically
accept that human beings
are merely one species in a
spectrum of other species.
Not uniquely unique but
unique like all others.
Like this, and we can zone in and see,
here we are.
And yet, and yet, even the most
scientifically minded of us
may harbor some residual
human exceptionalism.
In fact, I believe there
is a medical expression
of human exceptionalism
which is contributing
to this gulf between the fields.
And I became curios.
What is the extent of the overlap
in the pathology of humans
and animals and so I asked,
do non-human animals develop
heart attacks or failure?
Type I, type II diabetes?
Brain tumors, concussions, strokes?
Asthma, allergies,
breast cancer, leukemia,
infertility, painful
periods, sexual dysfunction?
And of course the answer to everyone
of those questions is yes.
Now of course our bad human habits
amplified the risk of disease.
It is the basis of preventative medicine.
And I have spent 25 years encouraging
improved diets and more activity.
And yet, although our bad human habits
may increase the risk of disease,
the essential vulnerability
to disease is ancient.
Let's quickly talk about two big killers,
breast cancer and heart disease.
We know that breast cancer
has a high human impact
on the human community,
it's the leading cause
of cancer among women.
But breast cancer is not unique to humans,
in fact, many of you
who have cats may know
that cats are at risk,
dogs can be as well.
This is a mastectomy scar from a cat
whose owner felt a mass
when she was petting her.
And in fact breast cancer has been found
in mammals of almost every
variety from polar bears
to elephants, to marsupials, llamas,
marine marine mammals, beluga whales.
In fact, notably, there seems to be
a particularly high rate of breast cancer
among some big cats.
We can talk about that in
another time why that might be.
But it's notable, one
fascinating connection
is that the reason that some
jaguars have a particularly
elevated rate of breast cancer
is probably related to a
mutation of the BRCA1 gene.
And it is the same mutation
that makes some human females
at elevated risk for breast cancer.
Now of course there are
regions of the world
where practices, habits,
genetics, diets are different,
and the rates of breast cancer are lower.
But that merely underscores the fact
that while our bad human habits
may increase the risk of our disease,
the essential vulnerability
to disease is ancient.
The age of mammals started
about 200 million years ago,
and I suspect that the
vulnerability therefore
to breast cancer can be stated
in a sense to be as old as that.
What about heart attacks?
So cardiovascular disease
it is the number one
cause of death globally.
In the United States those
statistics are amplified.
And we know that most
heart attacks are cause
by the progressive build up of
atherosclerosis in the arteries.
That eventually that
atherosclerosis breaks,
there is a blood clot that seizes
the flow of blood through the artery
and the muscle downstream dies.
And in this section of an artery,
you see the atherosclerosis, the plaque,
it has fractured, there is a blood clot
and this individual died of a stroke.
But this individual was not a human.
What we see here is an
Egyptian vulture rather,
flying in the base of the Himalayans.
And it turns out that if you look at
a phylogeny of atherosclerosis
across avian species,
every place that there is star,
there's at least one
species with in this order
in whom atherosclerosis
and stroke, heart attack,
and other clinical
syndromes have been seen.
Now, of course our bad human habits
amplify the risk of disease.
I've spent my life as a clinician,
helping patients modify their lifestyles.
We know that.
We know that bad human habits
do contribute to heart disease but
recognizing that after a sclerosis
and heart attacks and
strokes have been identified
in animals as varied as
walruses, dolphins, camels,
and of course human suggest
that well bad human habits may
amplify the risk of disease,
the essential vulnerability is ancient.
And again, the timeline
pointing to atherosclerosis.
And, if this is true
of the somatic diseases
like heart attack and breast cancer,
it is also true for mental illnesses.
There's a hair plucking syndrome
seen here in this picture,
where people pluck out the
hair of their eyelashes,
of their, any part of their body.
But it is remarkable that
this bears a similarity
to a hair plucking and
feather plucking syndrome
that is seen in some bird species.
You can see that this parrot has plucked,
denuded his thorax.
And it is notable that the
compulsive tail chasing
seen in bull terriers
treatable with Prozac.
Or the flank sucking,
the compulsive flank
sucking seen in dobermans,
treatable with Prozac.
There's similarities to the
compulsive behaviors we see
in some humans with obsessive
compulsive disorder.
And it is notable that
like some human beings
with anorexia nervosa,
some non-human animals
respond to social stress
by starving themselves sometimes to death.
While others deal with stress
by causing themselves to regurgitate.
Our bad human habits may
increase our risk of disease,
but the essential vulnerability
to disease is ancient.
Why is this important?
There are scientific and medical advances
that can come of thinking comparatively,
looking across species.
Translational medicine traditionally means
taking research that is
being done at the bench
in the laboratory and
bringing it to the bedside.
But I would suggest that
there is another way
of working translationally.
And that is by looking across
species and across time
for connections that
generate novel hypothesis
that can ultimately be
translated into science
that can save lives.
Further more, I believe these insights
have the potential to reduce
stigma and increase compassion
for people suffering from physical illness
and mental illness.
I would like to end by modifying the words
of the late great Susan Sontag
to reflect the species spanning
nature of health and disease
and the deep and ancient
connection we all share
not just with other human beings
but with all of the
patients on the planet.
She wrote,
"Illness is the night side of life,
"a more onerous citizenship.
"Everyone and everything who
is born holds dual citizenship,
"in the kingdom of the well
and in the kingdom of the sick.
"And although we all prefer
to use the good passport,
"sooner or later each of us is obliged
"to identify ourselves as
citizens of that other place."
Thank you for your attention.
(mellow piano music)
- I think I'll start off with a
evolutionarily very strange photo.
This is Heidi Klum, the
supermodel, with her four children.
And this is an almost unique sort of photo
in the mammalian kingdom.
And why is unique?
You won't see a chimpanzee mother
with four children under
her care at anyone time.
A chimpanzee mother raises
her offspring to independence
before she has the next child.
Same with gorillas with orangutans
and pretty well most
of all other primates.
A mother can only have another child
once the previous child is independent.
But here is Heidi and
she's got four children
all of different ages,
and all of them dependent
for their well-being
on parental care, maternal care.
Now, raising four children
at the time is hard work
and there's an interesting
evolutionary question
how human mothers are able to do this.
But it creates thoughts of
interactions among siblings
that you don't find elsewhere.
I should point out that there
are of course other mammals
that produce multiple
offspring at the same time.
They produce it later,
but in those cases all of those
offspring are the same age.
Now the existence of multiple
children all dependent for
at the same time from maternal care
means that tend to
compete amongst each other
for maternal care and attention.
And when I look at photos like these
I always like to look where are the hands?
And so if you look at this picture,
here is Heidi's right hand,
is holding her youngest child.
Her other hand is holding the hand
of her eldest daughter here.
And she is sufficiently rich
that she can afford another pair of hands
to look after her two other children.
So here's one of her
hands holding this child,
and then the second hand of the helper
is sort of hidden behind her body.
So, raising children is hard work.
Raising a child is not cost-free,
and sometimes people
challenge me about that.
But think about it,
if raising children weren't costly,
a natural selection X to maximize
lifetime reproductive success.
If there were no cost of child raising
mothers would have evolved to produce
an infinite number of offspring,
which they clearly don't do.
Offspring compete for
maternal care and attention.
That's if you're using your
right hand to hold one child,
you don't have the right hand available
to grab another child when
it's getting into danger.
Now there's another interesting
thing about that photo,
and this is that as it's well-known
Heidi's eldest daughter
has a different father
from her other three children.
And this genetically creates
an interesting asymmetry.
So all of these four children
are related to each other maternally.
If you pick a gene in Heidi
its got a one chance in two
of being present in each of her offspring.
These are all maternal half-sibs.
So they're all related maternally,
but the paternal genes of this child
unnecessarily absent from
the three siblings there.
So this child is unrelated
for her paternal genome
to Heidi's other three children.
And this leads
evolutionarily to a conflict
within the genomes of children
over the extraction of care from mothers
which ultimately translates
as cost of their care
having impacts on their siblings
who might be maternal half-sibs.
So maternal and paternal genes of a child
disagree over the value of half-siblings
who share one parent but not both parents.
And so here's the sort of a graph
that you've seen before in earlier talk.
I put fetus here but I'm just
referring to a child here.
We're looking at affects
on fitness of the child.
An affects on fitness of it's siblings.
And just dividing this space.
There are some sorts of outcomes,
some things that can happen
that are a benefit to the
child and to its siblings.
There are some things
that are a cost to a child
and to its siblings.
And then there is this own of trade offs
where some action is benefiting one child
at the cost to other children.
That's the holding of
one child in your hand,
meaning that that hand is not available
to look after other children.
So these are the science of
a trade off in parental care.
And so just looking at
what natural selection
maximizes in this situation,
so first of all I'm going to look at
natural selection acting
on genes of maternal origin
in a child with respect to
cost on maternal half-siblings.
The offspring of other fathers.
And so natural selection is predicted
to maximize this sum here.
This is the benefit to the child
and this is the cost of the
fitness of its siblings.
The child values itself
evolutionarily twice of your siblings
because the gene in the child
is definitely present in that child,
but it's only got a 50% chance.
This is a maternal gene of
being present in siblings.
So natural selection will favor behavior
when this sum is positive,
which is in this region
of the phase space,
what's its called,
matrilineal inclusive
fitness is increased.
But for paternally derived
genes in a maternal half-sib,
what's relevant is the effect
on the fitness of the child itself
because it is unrelated to its siblings.
So as long as the benefit
for the child is positive,
natural selection will favor
increasing demands on the mothers.
So combining those two situations
we have regions where there is an absence
of evolutionary conflict between genes
of maternal and paternal origin.
This is where they both benefit.
This is where they both suffer a cost,
a natural selection
would act against genes
with these sort of effects.
But then we have a zone of trade off
of conflict within the genome,
where genes of maternal
origin would benefit,
whether allocating more
resources to siblings
whereas genes of paternal
origin would benefit
from the child receiving
more maternal care itself.
This is where the cost benefit ratio
is setting in between a half and zero.
This is the zone of intragenomic conflict.
And for the second half of the talk
I'm just going to look at
some human genetic disorders
where genes so called
imprinted genes have an effect,
and these provide clues
about the action of this
evolutionary conflict
during human evolution.
Now an imprinted gene is a gene that
is expressed differently
whether you get it from your
mother or from your father.
It has an imprint a record
of its past history,
what sex of body it was in
the previous generation,
and that affects what it does
in the current generation.
So paternally-derived genes in offspring
are predicted to favor greater demands
on mothers than will
maternally-derived genes in offspring.
And so here we will look at an example
of a chromosome region
on human chromosome 11
where there are some imprinted genes.
Let's focus here.
This is a gene called IGF2 for
insulin-like growth factor 2.
Here we're looking at the chromosome
a child gets from its mother.
And on this chromosome
I've got a red dot there.
The IGF2 gene is not being expressed.
Where some the copy that the
child gets from its father
the IGF2 gene is being expressed.
IGF2 is a fatal growth enhancer.
This is a gene that is
promoting growth at the placenta
and is increasing birth weight
and it's not being expressed
when it comes from the mother,
but being expressed when
it comes from the father.
Now this is called imprinting
because this hasn't anything to do
with the DNA sequence itself.
In my body, the copy of IGF2
I got from my mother is silent,
but if I pass that silent
copy on to my children
it's going to be active in my children
because they got it from their father.
In this chromosome region
there is a second gene
with the opposite pattern of imprinting.
CDKN1C, this is a
cyclin-dependent kinase inhibitor.
This is an inhibitor of
progression through the cell cycle.
So this is stopping cells
dividing and growing larger.
So this is an inhibitor of growth,
and it shows the opposite
pattern of imprinting.
It's expressed off the
maternal chromosome.
So the gene coming from the mother
is acting to reduce growth.
Whereas the gene copy coming
from the father is silent.
So, in the essence, we have a situation
where simultaneously
during fetal development,
we have a paternal foot on the accelerator
of growth here of IGF2 being expressed
from the paternal
chromosome promoting growth.
The maternal foot is off the accelerator,
but the maternal foot is on
the break, reducing growth,
and the paternal foot in
the child in the same cells
is not applied to that break.
And normal fetal development is determined
by the balance of paternal acceleration
and maternal breaking.
And so this internal
conflict can be revealed
in rare genetic disorders
where parts of this process go wrong.
So I'll start off with,
I'll look at Beckwith-Wiedemann syndrome.
This is a fetal overgrowth syndrome.
So these children are born rather large.
I have a friend who had
Beckwith-Wiedemann syndrome as a child,
and she'd given me her
baby photo to look at.
So here she is.
She was about 13 pounds at birth.
Typical of Beckwith-Wiedemann syndrome,
she has macroglossia,
which is just what medical
people used to say,
it's Latin for having a large tongue.
I suspect evolutionarily this is,
the tongue muscle is the
pump during breastfeeding,
and so paternal genes are
particularly involved in promoting
the development of the tongue muscles.
Now what are the causes of
this fetal overgrowth syndrome?
In a number of cases,
individuals turned out to
have two paternal copies
of this chromosome region.
This is called paternal
uniparental disomy.
So in this case, they
have two copies of IGF2.
They have two paternal
feet on the accelerator,
and no maternal feet on the brake.
So they have fetal overgrowth.
It's also associated with a high risk
of a number of childhood cancers.
Some other people with the same diagnosis
of Beckwith-Wiedemann Syndrome,
the fetal overgrowth have a mutation
an inactivating mutation in
the maternal copy of CDKN1C.
So this is the break on fetal growth.
So the maternal copy which
is normally expressed
is inactivated by a mutation.
The paternal copy is
inactivated as normally occurs,
and so in this case
they've got a paternal foot
on the accelerator of growth
and no maternal foot on the brake.
And this is associated
with fetal overgrowth,
and the similar clinical diagnosis.
They'll apparently knot
with the increase risk
of childhood cancers.
Such a condition is interesting if,
if a male who had this mutation,
and had Beckwith-Wiedemann Syndrome
pass the mutant gene onto his children
they would have normal development,
because they would get a
normal gene from their mother
and the mutant gene that is
coming from the affected male
would have been inactivated anyway.
So this is a case where a mutation
is having an effect when
inherited from a parent upon sex
but not from a parent of the other.
Silver-Russell syndrome is a
intrauterine growth retardation syndrome.
And so here I have a picture
of two girls of the same age.
This little girl here has
Silver-Russell syndrome,
it's associated with
very low birth weights,
not associated with catch-up growth.
So if not treated, this
individuals grow up
to be very small adults.
It's also associated with severe
feeding difficulties as an infant.
Some individuals with
Silver-Russell syndrome
have two maternal copies
of this chromosome region.
So now they have no paternal foot
on the accelerator of growth.
And two maternal feet on the break
associated with intrauterine
growth retardation
and small birth weight.
Other individuals have a
loss of DNA methylation
at what is called the imprinting
control region 1 here.
This leads to the inactivation
of the paternal copy of IGF2.
So now they have no foot on
the accelerator of growth,
and that's associated with
intrauterine growth retardation.
For the final part of the tour,
I want to talk about a
different pair of syndromes
that are associated with
the different cluster
of imprinted genes.
This reside on human chromosome 15,
and here the imprinting
is specific to the brain
and doesn't occur in most of her tissues.
I won't go into the details
of naming these genes,
just to point out that
there are some genes,
like this one here,
that are not expressed on
the maternal chromosome,
but are expressed on
the paternal chromosome
and other genes with the
opposite pattern of expression
expressed on the maternal chromosome,
but not on the paternal chromosome.
Some interesting things in this region.
Here is where the
single-nucleotide polymorphism,
that in European populations
makes the difference
between blue and brown eyes resides.
And sitting here,
a gene that I won't talk about.
This gene MKRN3,
so this is a gene that is only expressed
when you get from your father
but not expressed from the mother.
When children have a mutation
in this paternally derived gene copy,
recent work from Brazil said,
they have precautions puberty
that they go through puberty
usually before age of 10 years.
So this is suggesting that the paternally
expressed gene on this chromosome
is inhibiting pubertal progression,
which raises some interesting
evolutionary questions.
Okay, so here is a young child
with Prader-Willi syndrome.
I'm going to focus on
the childhood symptoms
of Prader-Willi syndrome.
These children, some of you might know
in studying in the second
to third year of life,
they go from being anorexic,
having no appetite,
to becoming hypophagic and
they become massively obese.
But I'm just going to be focusing on
the symptoms that these children have
in the immediate perinatal period.
So this girl is showing the hypotonia
of Prader-Willi syndrome.
Most individuals with
Prader-Willi syndrome
have a deletion of the paternal
copy of this chromosome.
So they've only got
maternally expressed genes
coming from this region
and no paternal copy.
A few other people have two
maternal copies of this region,
and they have Prader-Willi syndrome.
So what this is showing is
the Prader-Willi syndrome is caused
by the absence of expression of genes
that come from the father.
Interestingly, an individuals
with maternal uniparental disomy,
this is one of the most
penetrant causes of psychosis.
Sitting down in this region of the region,
this is a GABAA-receptor cluster.
And there appears to be some sort
of parent of origin effect occurring here
that predisposing these individuals
to developing psychosis.
So Prader-Willi syndrome is associated
with the absence of expression
of paternally derived genes.
And therefore evolutionarily
this leads to a prediction
that Prader-Willi syndrome should exhibit
an exaggeration of traits
that reduce demands on mother.
So this region contains
paternal accelerators
on offspring demands on mothers.
We're taking away those paternal genes,
and so you should see in the child
reduced demands on the mother.
So let's look at the neonatal phenotype
in Prader-Willi syndrome.
It's associated with low muscle tension,
neonatal hypotonia.
With a weak cry,
these are low maintenance
children, and with poor suck.
So this children have little
to no interest in feeding,
and they have very weak or
non-existing suckling reflexes.
Usually they have to have a
chew put in to the stomach,
gavage feeding, to give
them adequate nutrition.
They show excessive sleepiness.
The child was put to that
bed and it stays asleep.
So this suggest that paternal genes
that are absent in Prader-Willi syndrome
promotes suckling and they
also promote wakefulness.
So in their absence you have
a child that doesn't suckle
and a child that sleeps through the night.
And I have suggest that evolutionarily
paternal genes are promoting
more intense suckling
and also night waking
in children in babies
as a way of essentially exhausting mothers
and delaying her return to fertility,
delaying the conception
of a younger sibling
who will compete for
maternal care and attention.
Interestingly deletions of precisely
the same chromosome region
caused a completely differently syndrome.
This is a boy with Angelman syndrome.
The majority of cases, 70%
of cases of Angelman syndrome
have a deletion of the
same chromosome region,
but in this case it's a deletion
of the maternal chromosome.
So they only have a paternal
copy of this region.
So now we would expect an
exaggeration of behaviors
that increased cost to mothers.
We know of couple of cases of women
with Prader-Willi syndrome
who had a deletion of
their paternal chromosome
that were fertile and had a child
and passed the deletion
onto their children.
Their child got it from their mother,
so the child of a
Prader-Willi syndrome woman
has Angelman syndrome.
Some other individuals
with Prader-Willi syndrome
have been activating mutations.
In this gene here UBE3A,
which is normally expressed
only on the maternal chromosome.
So now the maternal copy
is inactivated by mutation,
and the paternal copy is
inactivated by genomic imprinting.
And this suggest that Angelman syndrome
most of the symptoms are caused
by the absence of expression
of the maternally derived
copy of this gene UBE3A.
So Angelman syndrome is
predicted to exaggerate traits
that increase offspring
demands on mothers.
And I'll just look at some of the
symptoms of Angelman syndrome.
So Angelman syndrome is associate
with uncoordinated suck and swallow,
but these children do
not need to gavage fed,
as it if there's hyper activity
in the suckling reflex.
They get adequate nutrition,
so they don't show failure deprived.
They have adequate
nutrition as I've mentioned.
They are hypertonic rather than hypotonic.
They have ataxia, hyperactivity.
Particularly tiring for parents,
they have excessive wakefulness as babies.
I know of clinical reports of babies
who were awake 21 hours out of 24.
Parents are advised to get some sleep.
Sometimes they put the
child in a darkened room
and close the door.
Angelman syndrome is
associated with happy affect,
the laughing smiling child you
saw in the previous picture.
This is particular in interactions
with potential caregivers
and it's associated
with frequent laughter.
These are happy smiling children.
Curiously, this is associated
with a complete absence
of the development of speech,
or even of sign language,
so these children have some
degree of cognitive delay.
But the absence of speech
seems to be out of proportion
to the cognitive problems.
It seems to be a specific deficit
in this imprinted disorder.
The suggestion is the children
with Angelman syndrome
exhibit exaggerated attachment behaviors,
but normally engage maternal attention
and elicit maternal care.
This is the laughing, smiling baby
that the mother wants
to give attention to.
And I'll finish with another photo.
And just look at the hands in the photo.
So here we have mom holding on
to the hands of two children
and this child misses out and
doesn't get a maternal hand.
Thank you.
(mellow piano music)
- When we talk about medicine.
I think it's quite important
to think about what is medicine?
It is the study,
an intervention of human
physiological systems
and physical systems
and psychiatric systems
when they are dysregulated.
To attempt to correct what is going on.
To improve human health.
And in order to do that
we have to have a deep understanding
of not only the dysfunction
of these systems,
but how they function when
doing healthy things within our bodies.
And so to me the term
medicine really means
applied human biology.
And as every biologist knows
we have a favorite quote
which is that "Nothing
biology makes sense,
"except in the light of evolution."
And this means that to understand
the organizing principles
of any organism
biologically on this planet,
we need to understand
its evolutionary history
and the theories of selective pressures
that have shape that organism
to function the way it does
in the particular context
in which it finds itself.
And as an anthropologist who studies
maternal health and infant development,
I have a particularly favorite
adaptation that I care about.
And it is the systhesis of
milk from mammary glands
which is the defining characteristic
of our mammalian class.
It's as Barbara pointed out,
why mammals are at risk of breast cancer?
Because we have mammary glands.
And mother's milk
initially a random mutation
for a minor secretion that
perhaps hydrated young
or provided rudimentary immunofactors
has been shaped by hundreds
of millions of years
of evolution and natural selection
to become increasingly complex,
such that it provides
nourishment for young.
It provides comprehensive
immune protection
for the pathogens babies
are likely to encounter.
And it also provides bioactive hormones
from maternal circulation that
cross over into the infant
and influenced infant
physiological regulation.
It is due to this complex biofluid
that is food, medicine and signal
that has led every major governmental
and nongovernmental organization
to recognize mother's
milk as both liquid gold.
And breastfeeding as the gold standard
of early life input from the mother.
However,
because of the ubiquity of
milk within our environment
and it seeming replication in the form of
artificial breast milks that
you can buy at the store,
we have come to take milk for granted
and think of it as a standardized,
systematized simple kind of thing,
and we've lost side of the things
that make it incredibly
complex and special.
And it's that we have
not actually identified
what are liquid gold standards.
We do not have a systematic
understanding of milk,
how it varies?
What does variance does
when ingested by the infant?
And these are fundamental
things that we need to uncover
in order to better manage infant health
within the neonatal intensive care unit,
and better target our
public health intervention.
And so, I think an
evolutionary perspective
is incredibly important
in order to both design
and effectively target research studies,
but also to help inform our understanding
of this dynamic system.
Because lactation is a
complex adaptive system
in which natural selection
has shaped mother's physiology
and their mammary glands
to synthesize milk
in complex ways.
And there's a fundamental thing
that I think is very challenging
when we're thinking
about managing the health
of a mother and an infant.
Because we think about how do we optimize
that infant's outcome in that
particular time and place
for the challenges that infant is handling
or trying to handle.
And this is challenging,
because natural selection
has not shaped mothers
to optimized the outcome
of a particular infant.
Natural selection has
shaped mother's physiology
to allocate investment in young
across an entire reproductive career
to maximize her reproductive success
across her reproductive lifespan.
And because of this,
we see that there are going
to be a number of tradeoffs
in how she allocates
resources between her own body
and how she is nourishing her infant.
Just like I can only spend a dollar once,
an organism can only burn a calorie once,
and if that calories
burned on immune function
it's not available to allocate
word infant development.
And we see the signature
of these tradeoffs
broadly in how mothers
are synthesizing milk.
But this evolutionary
life history perspective
have not been systematically integrated
into medical approaches
within infant care management.
The important thing there is that
those food, medicine and signal of milk
is going to vary across all mothers.
The presence and abundance
of particular milk bioactives
is not standardized,
and in fact the signature in milk
across each individual mother
is going to be different.
When we look at milk synthesis
across every single potential
scale of consideration,
we find that milk varies.
It varies across species.
It varies across
populations within species.
Across individuals within population.
Within individual across lactations.
Within individual within a lactation.
And we can actually see
the synthesis of milk
and the composition of
particular bioactives
shift from hour to hour
throughout the day.
And so to kind of think
about what are the signatures
that we see in a milk
a mother synthesizes.
So Dr. Elizabeth Quinn has shown
that just the fat content in milk,
you can go to the store and it's processed
and you can get it at 3%, 2%, 1%
or where the fats entirely removed,
but across human populations
the mean value of the
fat content in their milk
is substantially variable.
We see gradients between
rural and urban communities
in things like their
minerals, fatty acids,
hormones and sugars within milk.
We see the signature of cultural ecology
in the form of subsistence
patterns in their milk.
This has been shown for
fatty acids, immunofactors,
sugars and minerals.
Melanie Martin now at
Yale University has shown
that among horticulturist in the Amazon
that the omega-3 fatty acid
concentration in their milk
is not only higher than that
which is found in the breast milk of women
living in the Ohio River Valley.
But their ratio of omega-3's to omega-6's
is closer to what we consider to be
most healthy for infants.
Across individuals,
when we look at dairy cows as
a model for lactation biology,
humans and monkeys as another
model for human biomedicine.
We find that maternal characteristics
are going to lead their signature in milk.
Mothers who have better body condition,
lower parasite loads, and
greater social capital
or access to resources are
going to synthesize milk
in different ways than mothers
who are more constrained.
We see this in the volume of
milk that they're producing,
the fat concentration
and hormonal signals.
Similarly across the same species
we find that the infants characteristics
are also implicated in
the variation of milk
that mothers are synthesizing.
So the age of the infant at birth
in terms of gestational age,
the infant's sex whether
it's male of female.
And whether or not the infant is sick
are all implicated in different aspects
of milk composition and production.
These differentiated
biological recipe in milk
has been found broadly across a number
of different mammal species.
And it's important to understand
that these does not necessarily mean
that mothers are making
better or worse milk
for either sons or daughters.
But where sons and daughters
have different developmental priorities,
different developmental trajectories,
we can expect that the milk
that mothers used to nourish them
is going to influenced aspects
of those developmental trajectories.
When we go to the grocery
store or the pharmacy
there's different deodorant
for men and women.
Right?
But when we go into the
infant formula section
in the grocery store,
it's one size fits all.
And we do not yet have enough
information scientifically
to say that that's not best practices.
We haven't allocated the
research effort to understanding,
could we get better infant
developmental outcomes
if we had more tailored milk for them?
For infants who don't have access
to breast milk for whatever reason.
Across time, we see that mothers
early in their reproductive career,
dairy cows, seals and
monkeys I worked with
that adolescent mothers
make different milk
than mature mothers,
that across parties, mothers
make different milks.
This can be the nutritional components
as well as a hormonal
components of their milk.
And the signatures that this
may leave in infant development
are still poorly understood.
So lactation is an
adaptive contingency system
in which mothers have
access to more resources
are able to up-regulate
aspects of milk synthesis.
Or mothers that are constrained
down-regulate milk synthesis
to protect their condition
for future reproduction.
And this is shown both through the milk
that their synthesizing and their
behavioral dynamic with their infants.
And this is a function
of maternal resources
and their allocations among
different tradeoff priorities.
An adolescent 13 year old human mother
is going to be constrained
in her capacity to synthesize milk.
So that means that clinical
support for that mother infant
that is going to have to
take into consideration
that the cascading trade-off allocations
between her condition and
the condition of her infant.
And this important because
where milk production is constrained,
where milk production is insufficient
we see impacts on infant developments.
So milk composition and
milk volume is implicated
in infant growth, their immune function,
how microbes colonized
their intestinal tract,
their cognition and their behavior.
You see this in animal model systems
in a variety of different human settings.
And this is quite important
because in the media
we're seeing a lot of push back
on the specialness of breast milk
or the importance of breast milk
because it's really centered
around the narrative
of best case scenario.
For full term infants
that are born healthy and raised
in an incredibly protected
and buffered environments,
the effect size that's
transferred by being breast fed
or formula fed is going
to be fairly moderate.
But when we anchor the narrative
to those best case scenarios
we lose sight of many situations
in which the consequences
can be quite a bit dire.
So if we think about the
premature infant born
in less than 39 weeks,
that ends up in, a very,
very young infants,
25, 27, 29 weeks of age
that spend a substantial amount of time
in neonatal intensive care unit.
Breast milk or bioactive
features of breast milk
can be absolutely
critical for their health.
If we think of children
growing up in spaces
with substantial infectious disease risk,
then the immunofactors that
are present in breast milk
and not found in other alternatives
are going to be very important.
In settings in which there's
this substantial risk
of development of allergies or other kinds
of autoimmune kinds of challenges,
then breast milk maybe a buffer to that.
And even when we think about
that best case scenario
where individuals are most buffered
and the affect sizes are most moderate.
When we scale those up across a population
the health consequences add up,
and the healthcare dollar
cost add up substantially.
So we need to think about
not just best case scenarios,
not just one child interactions,
but at public health
population levels as well.
So this is a complex adaptive system.
And we can use that
understanding of these systems
and how they've been
shaped by natural selection
to identify particular strategies
and targets for interventions.
So some aspects of milk synthesize
are going to be quite flexible,
some are going to represent constraints,
and some are going to be fixed
as a function of genotype
or other kinds of variables.
In this situations where this represent
trade-offs of the mother,
we can use public interventions,
access to resources,
social justice and public
health interventions
like the WIC program,
to help improve the resources
so mothers are not trading
off to the same extent
as they are when they
have fewer resources.
When the constraints become more fixed,
when there isn't a capacity
to influence mothers
to up-regulate their milk synthesis
or shift their milk composition,
then we have opportunities in
which evolutionary insights
can yield important advantages
to how we approach milk management.
So right now we see
that 20 million infants
are born premature across
the globe each year.
The vast majority of these
are happening in the global south.
And these infants are administered milk
as a clinical intervention.
So this is either donor milk, formula,
or other kinds of
commodified milk products,
which have their own
bioethical considerations.
Right now these milks
represent mean values
as though we know the gold standard.
And this is erasing of
a lot of the individual
or more specialized tailored
features of the milk.
And these products and interventions
are based off of mean values
among what we would call
or what Joe Henrich would
call weird populations.
Westernized, educated, industrialized,
rich, democratic populations.
Okay, weird.
They're weird.
And they do not necessarily
reflect ancestral conditions
or the diversity of milks
that mothers are making.
But if we make this our gold standard
and it's not actually the best target
for us to replicate or match,
then when we're going
down suboptimal pathway.
So we can think about,
what do we know about milk?
What has already been found out?
And can we from there
design clinical trials
and other kinds of studies
to see if there's added value
space within clinical care?
So right now in the NICU,
some form of milk is being provided.
Can we do better if we start thinking
in terms of precision milk
along with other aspects
of precision medicine?
So can we do better if
we match milk for the,
whether the child or the
baby is a son or a daughter?
Can we do better if we give
morning milk in the morning
and night milk at night?
Adults and children
have a circadian rhythm,
in which are glucocorticoids
are higher in the morning
and lower in the afternoon and
evening and while we sleep.
Babies don't have a circadian rhythm,
they get information
about a circadian rhythm
through their mother's milk.
So what happens when we
provide day milk at night?
Does that excite the baby's systems?
This is a empirical question
for which we do not have
published information at this time.
For babies that get milk.
Could we do better if we match
donors in a selective way?
That we add value by picking milk
from particular life history stages,
or mothers of particular
genotype in the donor options.
It's an empirical question,
we don't yet know.
The FUT2 genotype influences what sugars
and whether or not they're
fucosylated are present in milk,
and these are important for influencing
the microbial colonization's
of the infants guide.
Can we target pooling milk across mothers
to create a super milk that's
going to be quite important
for particularly
vulnerable or sick infants?
Can we mix glycans to maximize the health
of the microbial systems
colonizing the infants gut?
Can we provide particular
microbes to those infants?
Right now, all of the
milk processing techniques
in the neonatal intensive care unit
involved neutralizing
these components of milk
that we know are
potentially quite important.
And lastly,
can we co-opt and
bioengineer milk bioactives
from other species that are
solving evolutionary problems
that have importance for
infants in the NICU today?
So when you look the marsupials,
kangaroos, wallabies,
they're born at very,
very early stages of development.
They have very undeveloped lungs.
And there's milk
bioactives within the milk
that their mother synthesized,
that accelerate the development
of their lungs specifically.
Could it be possible to
replicate or bioengineer that
in ways that we can provide it to these
25, 27, 29 week old
infants who had huge risk
for pneumonial disease because
their lungs are undeveloped.
And there are people in Australia
working on answering
that question right now.
They're using an evolutionary perspective
of how natural selection has shaped
adaptations to solve problems,
that had implications
for the unique challenges
that humans faced in our
particular cultural context.
And lastly,
when most of these have been talking about
donor milks and bioengineering,
but there are many infants
who do not have access to milk
for a variety of reasons.
Their metabolic disorders,
other kinds of illnesses in which mothers
are not able to synthesize milk.
There's historical traumas
and cultural context
that make it very difficult.
There are infants who are raised
by wonderful families
that don't include a mom.
And these families rely in
very important ways on formula.
Artificial breast milk.
How do we make a better
artificial breast milk
that delivers more of the
important bioactives in milk
to help enhance those infants development?
These are the kinds of things
where we can take an
evolutionary perspective,
apply it to a variety of
clinical and cultural settings
to improve human health.
And this is what it means to
be thinking evolutionarily
to approach medical condition
challenges of human infants.
Thank you.
(mellow piano music)